hi welcome everybody how's everybody
doing
good
great
just wait for my presentation to start
cool so i'm rob i'm one of the hardware
engineers and today we're going to talk
about how comma actually works
um
click i'm not working
oh there it is
it's a little slow
you go to the next slide please
no
so today we're here to answer the
question how can something like comma
exist
so
like we support most of the cars
that have been shipped in the last five
years and like how does this actually
work because if you think about it like
we have all these different brands
uh they all work slightly differently
you would think they would all have like
different standards but somehow we
managed to build a system with only a
few engineers which works on most of the
cars that are sold in the last few years
so how does a motorcar actually work i
mean although probably most of you
already know that most uh that most cars
are filled with a bunch of electronics
uh
so we have a bunch of connectivity going
on we have the comfort system we have
the powertrain stuff which runs the
engine
uh we have an infotainment system but
most importantly most modern cars also
ship with an ada system so what does ada
stand for
this click is not working great
there it is
i'm pressing the top one it's not doing
anything
one back
there you go so an advanced drive
resistance system so this means this is
a system that's built for safety and for
comfort so it has both lane keep assist
which keeps you inside of the lane if
you're not paying attention probably
doesn't work very well on your car but
it also has
stuff like acc adaptive cruise control
to keep distance with car in front of
you and what we really care about is
that the system has control over the gas
and the brakes
this is really important for us because
that's obviously something we want to
control
cool so how does this add this ada
system look in most cars so usually you
have two systems uh which do the adas
which is the radar and you have the
vision system
so those are used uh the radar system is
used to measure the distance with the
car in front of you and you also have
the vision system to look at the lanes
and and give some more visual clues into
the system these then send messages over
to the actuators such as gas brakes and
steering
which then
control your car
cool so if we look at this from like a a
topology perspective we have all these
different systems uh so you usually have
the adas camera and the radar which we
already talked about you have brake
systems power steering engine control
sensors diagnostic stuff
does infotainment user interface all the
buttons in your car like everything
that's electrical in your car is
connected over these bus systems
on most cars these are actually divided
up into three different buses
keep pressing
oh it's the bottom one i see now
uh so you have the power train bus which
is the most important one so this runs
all your engine control stuff uh you
have a body bus which is a little bit
less important this runs like your
infant damage system um and all the
other buttons in your car and then
there's one extra bus which is a radar
bus usually they separate this one out
because there's a lot of data going on
it so you don't want to
have all that data on the auto buses
so if you want to control the car like
where do we want to be well first of all
we want to get the rate of points but we
also want to
see what the camera is actually sending
so you have all these bus systems what's
actually going on on these buses well
all these buses use a protocol that's
called can bus
this is used in most cars and it
basically consists of these messages
with which have an identifier and a data
portion and they get sent around the bus
providing all the data to the auto
modules
so this is for example one of the one of
the messages that goes around on the bus
so you can see there's two two lines
there they go uh out out to each other
which means this is a dominant bit you
have recessive bits and these that make
up the identifying the data portion and
some other stuff you don't really care
about
so why do all the cars use canvas i mean
this is kind of a kind of a wonder right
like you have all these cars they're all
baked by different brands and somehow
they all ended up with the same kind of
bus system
well it turns out that in 1996 when cars
weren't very electronically complex yet
they all uh
all were mandated to use a diagnostic
sport so which is called an obd2 port
you guys probably have seen this already
like below your dashboard there's a
sport which is used for diagnostics
um in the specification like it mentions
that you can use one of five buses of
which the most common one was can bus
and so all the car manufacturers just
chose the can bus and just went with it
um
now cars were very complex back then so
we usually only had this one can bus
going on but after that like they uh
they merged out and when they built all
the all electronic systems they just
went with what they already knew and
they just went with gambas
cool now you know how a car like kind of
works on the inside like how do we
actually take control over the car
so
controlling the car is basically three
different steps so first we have to
connect to the can buses
after that we have to figure out which
message is which because they they just
have an identifier which is a number and
they have a data portion which just
looks like random garbage
and then after that we have to
intercept it and send data control
messages
so let's first look at how we connect to
the canvas so if you go back to this
topology like like i already said like
we really care about the data on the
radar bus and we need to we care about
the messages which the adas camera can
send to the rest of the car
uh so the ada's camera is in control of
uh joining the radar and the vision data
and then providing all the acc messages
which control grass and brakes and then
also the lane keep assist messages which
can
put torque on the steering wheel to
steer your car
so where do we want to tap off we want
to tap off
there we go
back there we go so you want to top off
at this point
uh this point is kind of ideal because
it's right in the cabin like uh this
ada's camera is located behind your rear
view mirror so that's the ideal spot to
tap off these buses
you don't have to mess around in the
engine compartment or anything you can
just take this connector take it out and
then mess with it there
so if we simplify this diagram so we
have the radar system which sends
messages to the camera and the camera
system sends messages to the rest of the
car
so what do we do we just connect to the
radar we split apart the camera and and
the rest of the car and then use a scan
to usb interface to actually talk to the
car
the scan to usb interface is called the
panda
and then the open pilot device is the
part that runs all the application code
all the machine learning models which
actually then figures out which messages
to send
so to connect to the car we used to make
this thing called the giraffe
maybe some of you who've been around for
a long time still remember the giraffe
then we have the panda
if africa comes up there's the panda
there's the white panda this is the
first one we sold
and as you can see this is basically
just an obd2 port which has three can
buses on it and it has a usb connection
to go to the open pilot device which we
used to sell which was the eon
this is just a phone in a 3d printed
case with a heatsink uh it's pretty
simple
cool so if you put this all together it
kind of looks like this so it's it's
not the cleanest setup like a camera
cuff is gone um like giraffe's just
bungling down there there's a panda
plugged in you have usb connection which
this kind of flaky
and then the device mounted to your
windshield
it's all about these are these giraffes
so
we used to have basically like four
types of giraffes these are the main
ones that we sold so we had the toyota
one
which is common for all toyotas then we
had the honda bosch one which is for
honda cars but then with
a bosch camera installed and then we
also had honda harnesses for the nida
camera system now we actually have two
versions because you can anybody spot
the difference
um i mean disconnect those upside down
on one of them so with one day like
night i decided it would be really funny
to like flip the connector around so we
had to make another harness
cool so she wraps so it's not a very
clean install you saw that in the
picture uh there's a bunch of switches
on it so if like an open pilot device is
not connected uh the car buses will
still be separated so your car thinks
the camera isn't there the radar isn't
there so it throws all sorts of faults
uh there's also like a lot of variants
all very different they're hard to
manufacture because they're so different
and it's also terrible naming like who
knows what you're talking about if
you're talking about your giraffe
so drafts are cancelled
so then we went
on 2019 we rethought this whole
ecosystem and we came up with what's
called the car harness so car harness is
a very clean install you can put it all
behind your camera cover uh it has no
switches anymore so if you disconnect
your device uh it actually has a relay
inside
which switches your buses back together
so if you unplug your open pilot device
your car will just think there's nothing
nothing happened and everything will
work great car is happy
so this whole system is very generic
[Music]
so we have like the cabling system we
have the stuff that plugs into the obd
port which is generic for every car we
have the harness block which we
manufacture this has the relay in it and
the auto switching logic and then
there's one custom connector for every
car which is the car harness
connector so this one's very easy to
manufacture because most things are
common and it's also a great naming
scheme like everybody knows what you're
talking about if you're talking about a
harness
cool so we have all these different car
harness connectors because like at this
time we support i think 134 different
cars uh not only toyota and honda
anymore uh so we have all these
different connectors we we got all of
these made
so we have two for honda which we
already saw we have the nidak one and
the bosch one like now that there's a
harness connector we can actually just
flip it around and still fits
um we have the toyota one we have the
nissan one which also has two we have vw
one we have an fca one and subaru one
and then there's hyundai
they apparently didn't think it was
necessary to make a standard in the
company like most of these actually use
the same connector but some of the like
buses they just like pretended it was
funny to flip the high and the low pair
and it's like okay ship the car that way
so we're connected to the car buses this
is already figured out
now how do we know which message is
which because we have all we have all
these messages going on as you can see
like uh we did a log of all the messages
on the can bus this is a video of the
actual drive and you have all these
messages going on there's actually a lot
more there's a there's a whole bunch of
messages you all have this identifier
and then a bunch of random bytes like
which like change during the drive
so how do you figure out how to
uh what part the switch all this takes
quite a bit of reverse engineering
effort um
which we built a tool for called cabana
uh i think drew's gonna do a lightning
talk he's gonna talk a little bit more
about how to use this
but as you can see like you can label
all this data once you figure out which
is which and then we can actually see
like okay this message uh it's actually
for like wheel speeds so you have the
four different wheels of the car
uh so we we figured that out you can
plot this value so you can see it
corresponds with the picture now where
it's stationary for a while and suddenly
start moving and see all the wheel
speeds of the car
cool now we have all the messages
figured out
where do we actually store these
definitions um
so what industry standards
for these definitions is called a dbc
file which is basically a definition
file for every can message on the bus so
it's just this this large text file
which specifies like okay this
identifier is called this message uh
these bits and this meshes say this
now these aren't
available from any car manufacturers
because there are like internal secrets
so we created this project called
opendbc which we also in getup
which has all these reverse
dbc files for all the cars we support so
as you can see this is the one for the
civic which we were looking at before so
this is for example the wheel speed
message we were looking at with all the
four wheel speeds and then also it
checks them to make sure the message
arrived correctly
so what's what kind of messages go
around on the bus so you have sensor
values button states so if you press a
button like a bit toggles uh there's
control messages going on saying like
okay i want to accelerate by x amount of
meters per second squared uh there's
stuff about like what shows up on your
dashboard so you can throw arrow
messages on the dash there's a rate of
points going on from the radar
etc etc
okay we figured out which meshes which
and how to connect to the canvas what's
left
well we just need to figure out like
which message to actually send like how
do we figure out what the battle message
is to keep you inside of the lanes and
not just like drive out of the lanes and
then bounce back so we actually want to
stay in the middle of the lane
well for this we need to look at open
pilot without all the fluff
so openpower is made up of these all
these services which talk to each other
uh each service has this one specific
purpose
um we call them demons so that's why
everyone and uh every one of them ends
with a d so it's camera d model descends
and he controls the etc so we have the
camera d which is responsible for
sending camera frames to the model
and a model d just runs our ai models on
them and actually outputs the
information we care about so for example
we have camera phone with a mole input
overlaid
then we have sensibility which takes all
the values uh that the sensor outputs
and then uh
those get all sent to controls d control
z is a big blob of code um
it's most mostly mathematics with like
path planning and stuff which we'll look
into a little bit more
control z then actually generates the
car specific messages you want to send
which are then forwarded to the panda or
can to usb interface and then the panda
sends them over to the car such that the
car is
happy
so that's our
let's go back to one more so that's a
panda inside of that comma two if you
open up the case that's what you'll see
so there's an sdmi controller in here
which provides usb to the phone and then
it has this obdc connector which outputs
the cam buses back to the car
and then here's the harness connector
installed on the car
so after that
we'll look a little bit into uh what
controls he's doing uh so control z
basically exists with like three
big layers so the top layer is the
general uh longitudinal and lateral
planning so this basically means okay
the mole outputs we want to be on this
path which are actually over here like
what's the actual best plan to get on
the path that the model wants you to be
at
uh this then gets output to the control
loops which are very generic so they're
all um in si units or in like meters and
meters per second squared and stuff like
this
and they actually
um
go from the path to like the curvature
you want to be in
uh and then the curvature gets
gets uh converted into an angle and an
angle gets into a control loop which
then provides how much torque you
actually want to put on the wheel to get
to that path
beneath all of this which is all generic
there's all the car interfaces
so each
car make we support has its own little
interface which basically specifies okay
like how do we want to send these
messages what rate how do we fill them
in
et cetera et cetera what are the car
specific limitations
um and on average we managed to support
134 cars with only on average 45 lines
of code per car so this is really easy
to maintain we also don't really have to
own all these cars because a lot of this
code actually comes from the community
we only own i think six cars at coma
so a lot of this comes from community
contribution which is really nice
okay so now we figured out how to
control the car right so talk should be
over
well
no there's a fourth thing you have to
make sure that it's actually safe
uh because obviously you don't want to
be on the highway and then you will
suddenly start spinning like this
that's not a good thing
so how do we figure this out well from
the beginning comma set out to be very
safe so
we made this one text file explaining
very concisely
what our safety model is and this
basically boils down to two points
uh so the first is that the driver
always needs to be attentive and ready
to take over at all times so
uh comma two is a level two system which
means that it it requires a drive to
always be attentive and if it messes up
that the driver needs to be able to take
over
we
do this by enforcing that if you for
example press the brakes
or the gas that open pilot disengages
and you have full control of the car
again
the second part
means that the vehicle shouldn't alter
its trajectory too fast for a human to
take over
um
so for example if you're going fast on a
highway you don't want the car to swerve
suddenly and steer you off the road
this is enforced in
our panda safety library
so the panda safety library is this
piece of code which runs on the panda it
runs on on an stm32 which is an slb
rated microcontroller
is meant to be very simple so it doesn't
use a lot of external libraries it's
very easy to reason about and this
basically has
this basically enforces like for every
message if it's safe to send this
message or not so if you're going on a
highway and you want to suddenly steer
very hard the band is not going to allow
that so if even if like somebody messes
with open pilot code and you introduce a
bug or anything the panda will not allow
this message to be sent to ensure that
you're safe
so
quick example for example on the toyota
there's this acceleration message which
has id number 0x343
and it in it it has a 16 bit
signed value which basically tells the
car to accelerate or decelerate it's
divided by a thousand so in in the end
you get up uh with the limit you end up
with the limits minus 32 and 32 meters
per second squared
now i'm sure that a lot of you know that
1g is like 9 meters per second squared
so this is quite a big range so you
don't want your car to suddenly slam on
the brakes with three g's of force
uh so the panda enforces these limits
so we have a limit between -3 which is
pretty heartbreaking and we have a limit
of mine of 1.5 which is pretty fast
acceleration but still within our safety
model so the panda gets messages it
checks if it's in
between these limits and if it is it'll
allow the message if it's outside of
this limit it'll block the message and
you'll be safe
so
to circle back to the beginning of our
talk um
how can something like comma exist i
think it boils down to three different
points
so first
more car the cars are more similar than
they look at first glance so we know
with all the the obd2 stuff that they
all ended up using can bus except for a
few german brands which use flexway but
whatever
so they're all using canvas they all
have the same generic setup with the
radar connected to the camera and the
camera sending messages to the rest of
the car that's very nice they're all
accessible from the cabin so it's very
easy to build harder
then the second point is that most of
the cruise based code base is very
generic so you saw that for example
controls d which should be the one
generating the messages is even mostly
car independent so all the planet stuff
all the control stuff is very
independent and then finally
um the hardware difference is also
abstracted away with the car harness so
most of our harm our heart most of our
hardware system is very generic
with only the car harness connector
being the the part that really
differentiates them
thank you so any questions
[Applause]
um
yes i'm not sure if everybody heard the
question but the question is do we run
into issues with
oes oem systems detecting that we are
sending the messages inside instead of
the car itself
yes
now this this this doesn't really happen
uh because for one we just cut the can
bus in half we have all these messages
and the panda forwards every message
that comes through which we don't care
about so there's something with like
button states or something it just
passes it through and the card doesn't
even know it was there
then second of all we use the same
structure that the ada system uses
itself
so we just replace the control messages
it would send so the car doesn't really
know who is sending the messages like if
it's either the data system or if it's
open pilot so it completely mimics the
internal car system
yes
so questions about tesla
actually i own a tesla myself
so that's probably why it's one of the
carports
so i have an ap2 tesla
there's
the the autopilot module which is behind
the glovebox it also has this one
connected which goes to the radar and to
the car so i also built a harness for
that so i'm intercepting that and i'm
sending messages as if i was uh the
autopilot system now there's also the
people who
have very early teslas which don't have
the the ap system so which don't have
autopilot
uh so those are
also pretty big in our community with uh
adding open pilot to their car
it's it's i think open pilot is a lot
nicer on the highway at least um
i don't have uh longitudinal control on
my tesla yet uh so it does are still
doing gas and brakes so i still have all
the ghost braking issues that hazard
deals with uh but on the other hand i
think the longer journal is the lateral
control is really nice for an open pilot
oh thanks
first thanks for the presentation it was
really great thank you um
how do you come up with the values like
the 0.3 for deceleration like is there
any better way to do it besides just
following each other around and break
checking each other until yes there is
actually a better way so
there's this body called
iso
which enforces these limits on car
manufacturers themselves so they publish
all these specs all these standards
which say like okay do you have to have
a safe ada system a safe ac system you
need to be between these limits so we
looked at those limits and we actually
enforced those i think on some of our
actuarial values even like slightly
below the iso limits
uh so this just from uh from testing
ourselves we found that we found out
these limits
to be very safe
hey speaking of safety how are the
claims about safety validated
um
so the question was how are the claims
about safety validated uh well the panda
safety is this uh
part of the c code which is very generic
so it has uh um it doesn't have a lot of
interface with the rest of the panda
code so we actually build this into a
shared library ourselves and then every
time this changes it runs through
automated ci tests so we
actually tried to break it so we have
all these unit tests on the goat which
test every limited enforces and make
sure that that these limbs are always
always enforced also we try to
be
be uh
implementing the iso 26262 standard
which is also one of the
one of the c uh safety
uh definitions uh
which is i mean it's just good practice
if you're writing any of these codes
yeah actually i was going to ask about
that
iso 26262 and if you need to be
certified to it and how are you reaching
that
through software testing or
and and the hardware
um
well some of this uh just comes down to
static code analysis so for this we also
have automated tools to test this
but on the other hand um
it's um
it's still a level two system so
we need to ensure that this
uh
code doesn't mess up which we do with
our automated tests and other than that
we also still have the limits which are
usually present in the ecu's of the cars
so if you send a torque limit that's a
torque value that's too high and for
example a homeless car it won't even
accept that message so even on top of
that there's the ecu safety which is in
the car itself
also iso is a standard not a regulation
so there's
yeah that was the name i was looking for
so so okay so mr you're using mr c and
not src plus plus or
we're using
cpp check to check all the miss
regulations
um i was wondering how do you get like
the right can you get radar data from
the blind spot monitoring the two radars
on the back of the car
yeah so on uh
that depends on the car so on some cars
uh the blind spot radars are actually
available from the the power chain
canvas and sometimes they aren't but
also on a lot of cars we see that they
don't actually output any radar points
um so they actually only output like if
there's a car in the blind spot or not
so it's only one bit so it's not
extremely useful
we still use it though for our lane
change stuff so we check that there's no
card there if we have the data
but we're also working on trying to get
more data out of the blind spot radars
because they seem very interesting for
the future of comma
thanks for the presentation the car
harness is it
will it have ability to accept more
cameras in the future or i know george
is uh all about the one camera because
it's you know the potential is not
fulfilled but going forward we don't
actually use the camera images coming
from the adas camera because it doesn't
actually send that data out over the
canvas so we use our own internal camera
in our open pilot device
so the comma 2 which we now sell which
has one camera and for most stuff we do
that should be enough
um could you maybe speak to your
hardware fail-safes if there's like a
catastrophic failure in the comma system
that reconnects the can bus and the car
is able to yeah is it is it like a an
analog sort of thing on the board it is
implemented in hardware yes so we have
this relay which is powered by the panda
so the panda says okay i want to be in
control which then actually is a relay
splitting the buses apart and then
actually starts forwarding the messages
now this can fail in two ways so either
the relay stays
closed which is very easy to detect so
you just see like if a message still
went through which you didn't expect to
go through
uh and another way it can fail is that
it uh stays open and then the card just
will fall because it doesn't see all the
messages because we're not sending
everything
oem cars tend to fall in the safeway yes
yeah
anyone else with a question
my question is also in regard to the
range limits
do you always know that if it's out of
range that you can safely throw it away
or would you consider limiting it and
second one is if it's like on the lower
end of the range and the higher end of
the range is that also kind of something
you consider when executing those
messages
uh yes so a lot of these limits in the
safety code are actually based on speed
as well
so torque limits are based on speed
second
if we drop a message like this in
practice this shouldn't really happen
like this only happens if the open pilot
code uh messes up or if there's a bug
because in the open particle we also
tend to uh want to stay within those
limits so usually we stay in those
limits and everything is fine
if we do go outside of these limits and
this would pose a safety issue then we
would just block the message and uh go
on today if this continues for a long
time
and a lot of these messages get dropped
then the car will start complaining
because it does expect a certain uh a
certain frequency of these messages
great i've got a question back here
so
i think i have a question about
hardware and oems potentially in the
future locking out
foreign parts and the reason why i have
this thought is because i saw videos on
like the right to repair and how
different companies make it hard to
repair their software without
you know they're assigned specific
hardware and i was wondering is this
something com is going to consider in
the future where it's not a problem now
but oems might make it so that only
certain
pieces of hardware can communicate with
their systems to control the car
uh yes so well first of all
we tend to use the same message
structure as the internal components
itself so as long as there's not any
signing going on the card doesn't even
know the difference between their own
internal modules and uh what we are
sending
second of all there has been some uh
very recent car implementations which do
use the signing and that's that's
something we're we're working on
i'll break it if i need to
[Applause]
all right um so i just have a question i
think it's similar to what was asked
before but rather than dropping the
package would it be better to just clamp
it to the maximum value that
the limit you enforce well that's an
interesting question well
we don't do this because we don't want
the panda safety code to actually start
generating messages so dependent safety
code is designed from the bottom up to
only be able to read messages and block
them
if we don't do this if we actually allow
the panda to generate messages
this will make the system very hard to
reason about so you'll have open pilot
which we lock then sending a message and
the car reacting differently than what
we expect uh so we just dropped the
message and then we know this is very
easy to reason about and we know what
the car will actually do now in practice
this doesn't really happen because
openpower is pretty good at keeping it
between the limits
great and we're sending a mic upstairs
so you guys can we can hear you
um does anyone else have a question down
here
did you guys ever or do you plan to
maybe modify the firmware on any
existing car modules let's say if you
need to get around some limit that's
arbitrarily too low or too high on the
oem side
this is something that's been
going around in the community a little
bit
we don't actively endorse this or
support this
but there is some people who have
figured out how to alter these limits
especially on the honda cars which have
a pretty low steering limit
so yeah
we do block these users if they if they
change them to unsafe values
thanks again for great presentation um
one note
would be nice if you guys put it into
some kind of
document like explaining uh
architecture and all that because it's
very useful for somebody starting
another thing i wanted to ask um
with the cars for the cars with the
weird uh arrangement like hyundai
they have radar connected to different
place what what is coma planning to do
about it
um
while some of the cars have a slightly
different topology uh so i know on one
of the cars for example the 8s camera
sends to the radar and the radar
forwards it to the rest of the car uh
usually we do find a way to tap into
those cars as well though
sometimes
we just tap it off at the camera and
only control the lateral part of the
steering so we just control steering and
not gas and brakes
um which is an easy work around but
there's also all the harnesses floating
around which actually do uh pull it off
on a
split the bus at a different point which
makes us control the rest of the car
great got a question down here
um given that most of our cars are only
designed to keep ourselves within the
lane and we're extending that to
you know more active uh use of the
steering motors have you done any
research into if that shortens the
lifespan of our steering motors what the
implications might be there
um well
i think we can say pretty certainly that
this doesn't because these motors
they're not actually meant to provide
the ada system so not for linky persist
but they're actually there to provide
power steering so they actually put so
much torque on the wheel when you're
like just flinging the wheel around
yourself they actually put way more
torque on the wheel than we would uh
just driving it through the adas
messages so this wouldn't be uh this
wouldn't hit any hardware limitations at
all
for the dbc's you guys reverse engineer
do the companies care do they say
anything provide you guys feedback
i'm not sure if we ever got any feedback
on it but i'm pretty sure they don't
really
they don't probably even know it exists
um out of curiosity how does can fd
affect things is that something that you
guys need to consider and what are your
thoughts on it oh kind of d that's uh i
think we're going to talk about that a
little more today so
i'm not gonna say too much
so um
when you connect a device like carista
to your obd
um and you can unlock some features like
cracking the windows from your
key
do you have any messages like that that
you can use it's not really related to
self-driving but maybe you can detect
that the car is getting hot or something
and then just crack the windows
well yes i mean we have access to the
canvas so we can send any message we'd
like um
this is not something we'll support uh
officially of course but if people are
running forks uh some modified versions
of open pilot like they can certainly
implement this stuff
great do we have any more questions down
here
oh god here out
is there any plans for weather related
or or road condition
uh you know speed limits or checks say
freezing cold uh mountain pass
and uh
you gotta limit the uh torque
a bit so that your
safety uh increases
well i think it's more of a question for
the for the next speaker or research uh
research hat
because this is more an open pilot
question there's not really any any low
level implementation needed there
so we hear a lot about tesla over the
air updates do they go deep enough that
they would interfere with you would they
be able to
break your connection uh and break your
control over the car with an
over-the-air update
i don't think so um
no i mean we're just tapping off the
bus
they don't even know we're there so
are there any um are there any concerns
with manufacturers like forking open
pilot and creating their own
version of it in some way or like are
they concerned with you guys at all do
you have any comments on that
uh i don't know if they're concerned or
not but uh i mean it's an open source
project it's mit licensed so they're
free to do whatever they want with it
okay is there another question over here
sorry could you quickly speak to what
kind of hardware you use are you mostly
microcontroller based do you have fpgas
on board and
what kind of latency throughput problem
do you have between sending receiving
messages to like the core open pattern
back into the system
um i can't really come up with a number
about the total latency
but we do run all of our stuff at 100hz
and that seems to be more than fast
enough to get the throughput we need
canon is also not a time triggered
system so if the message comes a little
bit later like nobody cares about this
as far as which kind of hardware we use
on the panda is mainly an
stm32f4 microcontroller
which runs all the low-level embedded
real-time stuff
and then on the hardware side we have a
phone
which runs all the open pilot codes
basically
there are several features that use obd
ports like some of the insurance
companies now have dongles and t-mobile
has a dongle
have you had any thoughts about
integrating with such things or ways to
make them work do i have to pull my
comma if i want to get a better
insurance rate
um
we don't work with these kind of
companies with a pretty small team so
these are all features that are not
really that related to self-driving uh
so i don't think we will spend much time
in uh integrating this but as i said
like it's an open source project so if
anybody wants to make these
modifications they're more than welcome
to
because are there any other evolutionary
changes that you guys are thinking about
like car to car communication or
anything else
there's some stuff going on as uh
alluded by one of the questions so can
fd is an upcoming standard which
basically uh
makes sure that can bus can handle a lot
more data throughput and this is also
something we're looking into
great do we have any other questions
down here
all right thank you so uh so for
combustion cars you guys voted like a
sending message to uh we see you first
and we see you is going to send the talk
command to the engine but like for you
cards the panda probably can do
uh it can it can directly send the total
command to uh inverter have you guys try
that
i mean how do you send the commands to
the inverter of an electric car yeah for
e-cards you can use panda directly send
the torque command to inverter and kind
of bypass the
ecu
fundamentally these systems aren't very
different so they still
they're still an acc system which is
very similar to non-electric cars and
they also still send the command which
says like okay i want this amount of
acceleration of braking and the
invertible handle is exactly the same
way as a regular
fossil fuel car would
great
if we don't have oh we got some more
questions on here
a lot of questions
is there any worry as more cars have
over-the-air updates that they could
roll out something like the rav4 prime
encrypted can bus where you could have a
vehicle that works and then over the air
that encryption is rolled out or is that
too low level to worry about that in the
future
i wouldn't be worried about that if you
have a car right now which doesn't have
any encryption going on
they're not going to be able to do this
over the air like most of these cars
don't even have over the air updates
i think that's always the only big
manufacturer which really has that at
the moment
but also this this encryption stuff
usually requires a more advanced
microcontroller in all of the ecu's so
you can't just upgrade that over the air
so wouldn't be too worried
hey um can you also elaborate a little
bit on the next version of
hardware what is what is in the to-do
list like what you guys working for i'm
sorry i didn't fully understand like uh
next version of the hardware what uh
what is that what was then uh i mean
what's in the pipeline
oh
it's not my point to talk about today
have you considered building like a
flash utility in the open pilot so you
can actually do updates at the ec level
like true ota updates like for your
car's controllers
well no because for once uh
for one part we don't really want to do
easy ecu updates uh this attaches a lot
of the safety stuff which is internal to
the car
and second of all we don't really need
to do this like most cars have a pretty
good interface as it is so
this this is pretty complex and we
wouldn't want to support swallow
different cars obviously
great if that's it i will thank you so
much roba
[Applause]
you